WHITE HOUSE SHOWS A SLOWING
ECONOMY AND INFLATION GOING EVEN
HIGHER.
HERE WITH MORE LARRY CUTLER IS
WITH US.
I RODE A BOOK IN 2020 BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THAT IT WAS THE FIRST
ONE IN TEN YEARS, LIVE FREE OR
DIE.
CHAPTER FOUR.
SOCIALISM'S HISTORY OF FAILURE.
IT IS IN THE GREEN NEW DEAL
BASICALLY SOCIALISM AND DOESN'T
SOCIALISM ALWAYS END THE SAME
WAY.
AND MORE POVERTY AND HOW MUCH
FREEDOM YOU GIVE UP IN THE NAME
OF ALL SECURITY?
>> BY THE WAY I READ THE BOOK,
LET THE RECORD SHOW THAT I READ
THE BOOK.
THEY JUST PUT OUT NEW
PROJECTIONS, THIS IS THE
WHITE HOUSE PROJECTIONS.
SO OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS THEY
ESTIMATE TO THE AMERICAN ECONOMY
WILL GROW AT SLIGHTLY LESS THAN
2% A YEAR WHICH IS ALL OF THE
SOCIALISM HIGHER TAXES AND
REGULATION, AND WEALTHY COLLEGE
KIDS, IF ALL OF IT IS SO GOOD,
THEN WHY DON'T THEIR OWN
ESTIMATES SHOW THAT THEY HAVE
SHOWN A MUCH STRONGER LARGER
MORE PROSPEROUS ECONOMY.
IT'S LIKE SHOW ME THE BEEF.
OKAY, YOU THINK THAT YOU ARE SO
HOT, THEN SHOW ME THE RESULTS.
AND THEY CAN'T DO THAT.
IT IS AN ABSOLUTE FAILURE.
SO THEY HAVE THEIR GROWTH
NUMBERS AND MOCKED UP THEIR
INFLATION NUMBERS.
AND NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO FIB
ABOUT IT.
AND THIS STUDENT LOAN STUFF, YOU
KNOW, THE EDUCATION DEPARTMENT
WHICH HAS BECOME A HOTBED OF
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, THEY DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT LAWS.
THIS WAS OBAMA'S BRAINCHILD TO
STOP BANKS AND PRIVATE LENDERS
FROM MAKING IT LOST WHEN THEY
KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT CREDIT RISK
AND GIVE IT OVER TO THE
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT.
THAT'S WHERE THE STUDENT LOANS
HAVE GONE.
THEY SHOULD STOP THIS.
AND TAKE IT AWAY AND PUT BACK
INTO THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND MAKE
THEM PAY A MARKET RATE AND IF
THAT HAPPENS, THE INFLUENCE
WOULD PROBABLY SIMMER DOWN
PRETTY FAST.
>> Sean: IS AN AMAZING THAT
SOME OF THE GOES INTO THE TRADE
AND DOES NOT GO TO COLLEGE, WHAT
SHOULD BE FORCED TO PAY
SOMEBODY'S LOAN?
I DID TAKE OUT A STUDENT LOAN
AND DID WORK FULL-TIME JOBS AND
I WENT TO COLLEGE.
WHY DO I HAVE TO PAY FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE'S LOAN WHEN I
WORKED HARD TO PAY MY OWN WAY TO
GET THROUGH COLLEGE TO THE POINT
THAT I GOT TO IT AND FINISHED?
WHY SHOULD I HAVE TO PAY?
>> THE SHORT ANSWER IS YOU SHOWN
IT, THIS IS ALL THIS REALLY IS,
TRYING TO BOLSTER UP THE SAGGING
NUMBERS ON YOUNG PEOPLE.
BUT IT WILL NOT WORK BECAUSE
THERE IS A BIG RESPONSIBILITY.
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT YOU SAID, AND I
TOOK OUT SOME LOANS FOR GRADUATE
SCHOOL BUT DID NOT PAY THEM
BACK.
MOST FOLKS HONOR THEIR
OBLIGATIONS IN THIS IDEA OF
STUDENT LOAN DEFAULT IS
RELATIVELY NEW.